can you help us determine a stage versus
a turning point yeah basically it's just
a stage is a sequence of events in the
story it covers a span of time a turning
point is a single event that happens to
the hero so a stage would be we meet the
hero we see our living or everyday life
we maybe meet the villain in the piece
we meet other characters her best friend
something like that or in stage two she
arrives at this new job if that's her
new situation we meet the boss she has
some problems she has co-workers she
meets the guy who's going to be the the
romance character or the love interest
those are stages they are sequences of
events but the opportunity is going to
be a single event that happens to her
such as in that example I just made up
the opportunity would be she gets the
new job ok or the change of plans would
be she is she is told she can have a
promotion if she can design a new house
for a billionaire and so her goal in the
movie becomes to design a house for a
billionaire by the way I'm making these
up that's why that would be a terrible
movie so don't have to I'm not giving
anyone listening to this don't take that
as an example of a good idea you should
pursue I'm just I shouldn't make stuff
up you know off the top of my head let's
take let's take an example from a real
movie one of my favorites this year
Jason Bourne okay
Stage one we see him he's down in Turkey
I think or the border of Turkey he earns
money by going getting into fights and
knocking these brutish guys out
he's obviously unhappy and and we see
that he's just sort of stuck in this
identity of a guy who has no home and no
connection and no real identity in the
traditional sense he doesn't really know
who he is is he Jason Bourne or is he
really the guy who became Jason Bourne
or so on so all of that is a sequence
it's a whole series of events that's a
stage and we cut away from
him during that stage and and see the
Julia Stiles character as she breaks
into this facility that the CIA runs or
NSA or whatever it is and she steals
these things we don't know why that's a
stage it's a whole lot of scenes strung
together the opportunity is a single
event he's in this fight and he sees she
shows up in his life and is coming to
him and now he's in a new situation what
am I going to do now that this woman
from my past who knows the truth of who
I am who I apparently had an affair with
once before I lost my memory and so on
what am I going to do and so now it's a
new sequence of events she tells him
what's going on they have to go on the
run from a guy she has to give him the
flash drive etc and we see new villains
and we see what's going on at the NSA as
they try and try and stop him so again a
stage is a sequence of events a turning
point is a a single event that happens
to the hero
you